all right let's jump back into the game
so rookie four played
yeah lookie for knight d6 uh everything
is forced i mean using the fact that the
knight on e7 is
vulnerable rookie two had to be played
and
now black doesn't have this tempo
anymore on the other hand
how do you maybe some knight b5 knight
d4 96
is is that a root because after knight
b5 if you
knight f5 then i'm just in time to go
knight d4
aha but then he played the movie dc okay
very natural
you occupy the third rank stop any
any black stream is to get his knight to
um to f4 somehow and i wonder if knight
h8 knight g6 could be an idea eyeing
both these squares
yeah and also very importantly you stop
any kind of 95 tempos
knight on f7 is is quite nice on the
other end okay knight h8
feels yeah look easy you take control
you take contour i mean these are the
positions that usually nothing really
dramatic happens but the thing is peter
that if now black refuses to trade rooks
for example a move like rook d2
white could actually improve his
position with rook f3
check and if you go king g7 or king g6
says knight e7
but you do have to move king e6 still
yeah i have two
not easy yeah i have to move to e6
yeah really really difficult to
very difficult to say but this is the
only
only game in progress yeah yeah this is
not the only game all the other games
had been drawn and anish has won very
important win for him
and it reminds me when yesterday he was
interviewed he and people ask him so do
you feel any stress
that and then he said stress by playing
chess really
i mean it also shows that yeah how much
he loves chess and
uh how much he he cares about playing
chess and playing good chess not not
neces i mean of course if
playing good chess and this art comes
together it's it's wonderful but
okay i i actually love this interview a
lot because it shows that
yeah this is this is the right attitude
and actually thanks to this attitude you
can come back
because if you feel i mean you are
stressing yourself about
oh what will happen then it's it's very
difficult because you take it like this
that
okay i played good chess but it it was
back
i mean it backfired it was not
successful let me just
keep enjoying what i'm doing then the
result might might come to you
and we also saw that confidence in his
tweet uh today saying that his
comeback has been scheduled for day two
and rookie three i was just going to say
peter that
after rook d7 white did have the option
to go rook f3 if you can quickly take a
look at that
because uh after rook f3 black has to go
king to g7
any other move white goes into a king
pawn end game by taking on f7
uh wow i mean king e6 runs into picks f7
yeah
and you capture with any any piece
there's a night for picking up the rook
and you win the kingpin end game but
after rook f3
black had the option to go king g7 still
keeping things under control
yeah but it's it's kind of scary and
look at this danielle down to 45 seconds
on the clock
daniel is back down to 45 yeah he goes
knight h80 he
he kind of feels that i have to go
knight h8 because that was my
whole plan with with knight f7 and i
go on video yeah that i have to be
consistent yeah
otherwise if i put this knight on epson
and i don't know what to do with it then
then it might be very dangerous in
with little time on the clock and i
really like this re-rooting of the
knight from d6 to f7 to h8 it looks
uh it looks strange on h8 but once it
comes to g6 everything in life makes
sense
because you want that knight on f4 or h4
yeah now the question how do you stop it
can you stop it
can you stop it but but i mean okay for
example
look actually check runs into for
example king g7
and uh and i gonna go knight g6
95 runs into rookie seven exactly and
then if you protect
i go knight g6 and if i change the
knights of course it's a dead draw
so yeah not easy for magnus and mine was
also down to one minute
five seconds basically
[Music]
he really needs to have a good plan
because if black gets knight g6 and
start creating his counter play then
then
it's it's very hard to imagine white
really keeping those
winning practical winning chances which
usually you can always shuffle around
and play a game forever
knight b8
on the board i mean where is this knight
heading
usually you bring the knight from b8
back to c6 nothing
nice from c6 going to b8 does it mean
that
somehow magnus wants to root it through
a6 c5 to e4
is that very slow i mean black can just
go
play the move rook to b7 now and then
perhaps the
rook b7 played hitting the knight uh
maybe he wants to go knight
c with knight c6 back you can at least
repeat because the point was that after
he's gone rook a6 check first
king g7 and then uh maybe knight c6 is
the point so that you can try and trade
it off with rookie seven next
let's see that pediatric ah this is you
know this is the idea that he just
understood that he cannot stop knight f4
and then he doesn't care he got the
sixth
rank knight c6 you go knight g6 he goes
knight d4
and he's trying to go knight f5 himself
and then if you go
knight f4 check you just move your king
away
and you are starting with knight f5
check and then they look gonna hit the
h6 pawn it's
isn't drew k7 an option or do you think
that ending why black is easily holding
if instead of knight d4 white just
trades the rooks
[Music]
it looks very little pawns though very
less spawns on the board
yeah with this fixed structure it it
does feel more drawish i mean
if this knight d4 for example works
nicely
i mean okay of course there is no reason
to play knight f4 check you can go
knight h4 but still
king g3 but okay
nothing look on b7 is misplaced because
if any check
or any activity it looks okay i can go
maybe rook b1
i can create my own agenda yeah so maybe
actually magnus has in mind to
to to change the rooks okay he has both
options
and i'm afraid that we got stuck a
little bit yeah and we see
a lot of action we see our idea peter he
got the knight back on d4 and rook b1
was played
yeah yeah exactly the line that we
discussed
is on the board f for g1 checking after
luji to king f1
[Music]
yeah well still a lot of dynamics in the
position because
now black has to decide i mean gtx f4 is
is the move that you basically want to
play because you don't want to allow f5
but on the other end if you
uh he opted for d2 knight e6 check
he wants to set up the knight f3 knight
h2 idea
yeah he went king f7 and i wonder peter
if after fg5
uh can black go knight f3 he's gone for
it so knight h2 is the three
g6 check wow you can't take king g6
because of knight d4 it loses on the
spot so he has to go
what's a good square for the king you go
king e7 now
yeah you're you seven that's that's on
the board and not okay
wow oh my god this is looking magnus has
done it again i think peter he has just
in very carlson-esque style
uh made something out of nothing yeah
well
i mean okay but this is the point when
you are pulling up and you can
keep on putting the pressure on your
opponent and okay this knight v8 2k6
this was uh this was a wonderful
maneuver which kind of i think this
balanced
daniel because he felt like he is doing
everything nicely with this little thing
the night knight h8 knight g6 and
that should be that should be it you go
down on the clock
and suddenly you encounter some problems
then you don't want to be
tortured by opponent you tell yourself
ah but there is this beautiful
uh perpetual check idea you go for it
and then magnus
finds the beautiful refutation yeah this
is navi the trap knight on h2
it's it's game over king g5 runs into g7
i mean you cannot you cannot even put up
any fight and white is the thing to play
the move look a5
cutting off the king and and that's it
wow that is some incredible technique by
magnus
yeah that that knight v8 knight b8 move
yeah
and i think peter the point was that he
could not we'll maybe take a look at
that moment right after the game
finishes so let's stick with our live
position right now because both players
are down to seconds
magnus in a completely winning position
now king g7 would have run into knight
h5 check so he goes king e5
how is knight h5 anyway g7 is coming in
next and that's it
daniel dubois has had enough he resigns
uh
definitely a very disappointing i think
lost
not for the result peter but it looked
like daniel was so close
to keeping this together yeah exactly i
mean here after knight achieved it
looked like wow beautiful defense
white has in fact almost zero chances to
continue and then magnus finds this
incredible 98 i mean if if people start
analyzing them maybe they will see okay
knight v8 was nothing special but for
the practical game then
your opponent kind of almost feels sure
that he has the setup
it doesn't matter i have 20 seconds on
the clock i'm gonna go knight g6 i will
have my knight implemented on
f4 and i will simply be always having
enough counter play no matter how much
time i have
and then this night be it completely
disbalances this whole plan
uh completely new scenarios are coming
now looking back
black could have actually played maybe
the move luke d6
which stops any kind of look a6 checks
but it
invites rk6 looking back maybe daniel
says that ah of course i should have
played the looks and
this night end game is maybe
drawish but during the game you i
believe that he felt like
the knight and look with coming the
night coming to f4 is better than just
playing this end game so he relied on
his feelings
now that he lost the game of course he
will tell you that or any position was
better than that one
uh what i got in the game but that's why
this night beat was so
so incredibly powerful because with 30
40 seconds on the clock to decide all
this
he went for this natural way look at
look b7 and all of a sudden check king
g7 knight c6
knight g6 knight before completely new
dynamic started which
finally he was not able to to handle
that knight beat is a very subtle point
in peter if you can just uh
go back a few moves when white did when
magnus did play knight b8
i think that after rook d6 magnus's idea
was not to trade because if that was the
point he perhaps would have gone drook
a6 before playing knight b8
and after rook a6 trading black can
simply even trade off one more pawn with
the move king g6 and h5
immediately this would have definitely
uh
i think gone the way daniel wanted to h5
i think you first go king g6 and then h5
try and trade off one more pawn
but the real point that i think is
really interesting peter is that if
instead of knight b8
making sure that black's rook goes to a
position that's not ideal
white does play rook a6 first then
black can simply go rook d6 and you kind
of get what you want then
with black so knight p8 rook b7 was a
maneuver to make sure that black doesn't
have this defense of rook d6